we've got a lot to talk about this
morning and for a more in-depth look
we're joined by Oh Sita one AVO staff
writer at Slate covering politics Oh
Sita good morning morning let's talk
about the tax reform plan which is the
president's biggest legislative victory
how critical do you think it was for the
administration to get this done before
the end of the year no it was pretty
critical and it's a big victory not just
for the Trump administration but for the
Republican Party in general this is
gonna be the fourth or fifth largest tax
cut in American history it's the biggest
one since the Tax Reform Act of 1986 so
if you're a fan of Republican orthodoxy
on tax policy you feel pretty good and
obviously but this is administration has
had a lot of fits and starts with its
legislative agenda we saw that with the
attempts to repeal no place for public
care so this is really their first
unqualified success and it was very
important for them I think to show that
they were capable of succeeding
legislatively on something you know they
get a legislative victory but polls
still show that there are a lot of
Americans who are not happy with this
does this have the potential to come
back and bite them I think it might
already be biting them I mean we saw a
Monmouth poll earlier this week that
said 47% of Americans plurality said
that they disapproved there other polls
they're more positive but at best
Americans are pretty evenly split on
this and what's worse for Republicans
they're actually a lot of Americans who
think that their taxes are going to go
up right if you believe the Monmouth
poll about half the public thinks this
and so you know do you think they'll see
a shift though if if they start actually
getting tax refunds do you think that'll
change their perception of it it
definitely might but you know you're not
gonna see the full effect of this on the
American taxpayer until you're filing
their taxes in 2019
yeah which means that the Republicans
are going to have to trust that the
public takes them out they're worried
about the benefits of a lot of this
stuff and we're seeing now that when you
pull people about the party that they
trust on taxes Democrats according to a
Wall Street journal/nbc poll have taken
the lead on that issue for the first
time in a couple of years it's what does
that mean for the midterms because
that's gonna be before they see the full
effect yeah you know I think that
basically we already know what the
Democratic messaging is gonna be we saw
Nancy Pelosi say earlier this week that
this represented an attempt to create a
permanent plutocracy you can already
predict the ads so you know it's going
to be a big issue if the Democrats
succeed and making it one and keeping
the spotlight on it obviously the
midterms are about an eternity from now
but you know I think that you could be
hard-pressed to craft a better bill for
Democratic
messaging this one the skew of the
benefits towards the wealthy is not
something that's easy to explain in the
populist political climate so I think
the Democrats are gonna have a pretty
easy time crafting this into their
already existing narratives about the
Republican Party
we heard the chip Reid talking about the
the GOP is interest now and the
president's interests particularly in
looking at infrastructure and funding
infrastructure spending but his chip
said he's he's not likely to get
Democratic votes which he needs
absolutely it is is are we are we headed
into a year leading up to the midterms
in which there's gonna be absolutely no
bipartisan cooperation whatsoever well
apart from infrastructure there are
actually two issues smaller issues than
big infrastructure bills but still
important issues where we could see
action with this stopgap funding bill
notions passed this week they punted on
ship the Children's Health Insurance
Program and they also punted on Dhaka
these are both issues with a fair amount
of bipartisan port for actually
achieving some kind of solution
Authority negotiations on both of those
friends with Dhaka I mean Democrats
would like to see a clean bill
Republicans would like to see funding
for border security other immigration
measures as far as chip goes they're
basically at an impasse over how to fund
things but these are basically issues
where there's actually time pressure the
Democrats and Republicans to come to
some kind of solution 122 people lose
their daca status a day as long as this
maintains you know as long as this is
still an impasse with chip I mean
they're afraid that you know as many as
two million people could lose funding
too many children lose funding in
January thankfully they were able to
pass their stopgap funding measure until
March but you know these are two issues
where there's a lot of time pressure to
actually have an impact and I think that
doesn't think it would draw Democrats
and Republicans closer all right I'll
see to why Navy thank you very much for
the very latest